all right well democrats and republicans
might not all be on the same page when
it comes to
uh covet 19 relief but they appear to be
unanimously against facebook
and charging that it has simply gotten
too big for its britches
some 46 attorneys general at a minimum
part of a class-action battle against
facebook that says
it has simply become not only too big
but uh an anti-trust problem the likes
of which
it has rarely seen or some of these
attorneys general have rarely seen
certainly in recent history josh stein
joins us right now the north carolina
democratic attorney general who was kind
enough to join us on this saturday
attorney uh general thank you very much
for joining us
what is your number one and primary beef
and 45 of your colleagues about
the way facebook does its business yeah
well
facebook is a monopoly they absolutely
dominate
the social networking site space which
we have all come
to depend on i mean they were massive
and uh
incredibly powerful before the pandemic
but since we live so much of our lives
on the internet now
it's how we connect with our our aunts
uncles
our friends our classmates all of that
and they've used that massive power
which they have as a monopoly
to maintain it they've squelched
competition
and that hurts consumers so what we want
is to see
free competition in the social
networking sites space
so that consumers have meaningful choice
so break them up that could be part of
it
what we want is for the court to block
them first of all from engaging in any
anti-competitive behavior
going forward to require facebook to
notify the state ag's before they do
more acquisitions
and whatever relief is necessary and
that could include
uh divesting lines of business we'll
have to figure all that out as we go
forward with the case
technology always changes as you know
sir and some people are saying the
villain you see today
could be just the dinosaur tomorrow and
then that
this is a waste of time what do you say
well i i disagree
um technology does change all the time
but when somebody grows and facebook
brought all manner of innovation to
social networking when they grow
due to whatever they're bringing to the
market if once they become
the monopoly they then use that power
to keep anyone else from emerging that's
what violates the law it's not the fact
that they're big
it's that they're using their monopoly
power to squelch that competition
uh and really degrade the services for
consumers the
privacy protections have diminished the
fake accounts have exploded got it so
the battle goes on i don't mean to jump
on you uh justin the north carolina
attorney general we have put out calls
to facebook non-return